miran were here at the Phoenix tomorrow
in London for the screening and Q&A for
your film book down you star in the film
why don't you tell us a little bit about
your character my character is called
Ely and she's a graphic novelist art
school dropouts and she's always doing
something so she's either spying on her
neighbors taking Polaroid's of the
different neighbors who come and go from
her flat especially Jacob who she bailed
sort of crush for and instead of curious
to meet him and get to know him and she
also and works in a big shot and she
also helps mrs. Nichols the women
upstairs to talk to her dead husband and
to comfort her now it's a film that I
was saying to a saint to Brian early
it's a film that almost didn't get made
and it's partly because of you Brian
showing those first 30 pages that he'd
written that the film did actually get
me because you encouraged him to finish
writing it now what was it you saw in
those first 30 pages that excited you I
think at the time I was doing a lot of
them period dramas and in class and
acting training in New York and please
and so it was a nice refreshing change
to read a script that was a comedy drama
that had really quirky characters and it
was a modern piece and then I just
really you know I laughed out loud I I
really fell in love with the characters
and the story and was really touched and
I just really thought you know this has
to be finished I want to read the rest
of it firstly and then I want to be part
of this world and you were able in a way
to contribute a little bit weren't you
as he was writing that and certainly as
the process went on to the character's
development i believe yeah and O'Brien
is Betty and he likes to hear your view
on things he's very open he's he likes
to have your opinion on things and so we
worked together and to make aliyah Phil
character and how did you get into a
Lee's character how did you get under
her skin so you had a few interesting
ways I believe well
and tears of behavior I did the things
that she did I went to life art drawing
classes I am I drew and sketched
everyday in a sketchbook I spied on my
neighbors and then I had to move home
and then and I also listen to the music
she listened to and I just it took a
long time to really feel like I was
really rather than just you know not
really feeling like quite fit the part
and but that's just the kind of slow
process and a lot of its just believing
in yourself so yeah it's the kind of
long process and I heard that you even
said to yourself well this is a street
she's gonna live in in Glasgow and you
went to find the house that it was as
well and I can't possibly reveal my
sources with it right yes I didn't know
it you knew that em that's quite a scary
and yes I did I i chose the exact house
and the exact streets and I just had to
you know really know who she was because
I had to play her and ogled respect for
the character I think you should really
go the effort to build up a back history
and what would you like to do next now
mirror and now that book down is in
cinemas isn't getting booked out what's
gonna be next for you I'd love to get my
hands on a script that inspires me as
much as brains dead and to work with the
director and this is passionate creative
and intelligent as brain and that would
be amazing
you